in the amazon basin in the lowland
forests of bolivia archaeologists have
discovered new evidence of an ancient
civilization nobody expected that kind
of of society in that region using lidar
technology researchers peeled back the
dense vegetation to reveal huge
structures hidden beneath the trees
pyramids 20 meters high the whole region
has been so densely habitated during the
prehispanic time
that's incredible to believe now in an
area once thought to be of little
interest to archaeologists hundreds of
new sites have been uncovered there is
new civilization new culture waiting for
us to study them
it's a sort of a dream coming true
archaeologist heiko promise has spent
most of his career working in amazonia
most of people say what are you doing
there
when i went to amazon area because it's
supposed that in the amazon region there
was almost nothing but
small tribes but for haiko the amazon
held bigger secrets
in 1999 he started to investigate large
mounds in the lowlands of bolivia
if you go to the southeast of the
youngster which is a
savannah region in the lowlands of
bolivia people will tell you of the
lords
those those lolas are
mounds
that exist over there and that are
normally
covered by vegetation when haiko and his
colleagues started excavating some of
these mounds archaeologists had
theorized that they were rubbish heaps
the result of waste accumulated over
centuries
but hidden beneath the earth the teams
found evidence of rectangular platforms
graves and artifacts signs of a society
with a social hierarchy we found
something like 120
graves in in that site
and some did have offerings and they
were at special locations so
all those data combined showed that
society itself was much more complex
than
anybody had
supposed before so in 2019 a team set
out by helicopter to try and uncover the
true scale of this ancient civilization
with the help of lidar technology
you
use a laser
adapted to
the helicopter or small aircraft
and then you fly over an area and by the
reflections of the laser you get the
distance from the objects and the
fascinating thing is that
you can eliminate virtually
digitally the vegetation afterwards the
lidar revealed more than anyone had
expected beneath the thick canopy were
structures rectangular platforms conical
pyramids defensive banks canals
reservoirs and long straight causeways
connecting hundreds more settlements
large and small if you are overflying
those signs you won't see anything but
trees
vegetation and
when you see afterwards a lot of images
well you know you have been flying over
sites archaeological sites
you see everything the discovery is part
of a huge change in what archaeologists
think about the history of the amazon if
we
talk about amazonia
we generally talking about
people without agriculture
and
to recognize as a first step that they
were sedentary and that's a
agriculturalist
that is a big step
even just from the air the newly found
settlements give hints of a complex and
unexpected way of living
in near to every site in one hour of
walking you will find at least one other
side
nobody expected that kind of of society
in that region
that's a new thing
yeah to find a densely populated area
with
settlements much larger
than before
so what does this tell us about the
casarabe culture the name given to the
people who constructed these new
settlements and the two mounds that
heiko and colleagues already excavated
when i'm giving conferences in bolivia
and people ask over there and and who
were those people that constructed those
mountains and say well
we just commenced our studies over here
we don't know if if i were working in
switzerland or in germany and after
excavating at two sides i would
damn to say
it's like that it's like that so what
got me off the country
so we need to
to be patient and
and wait for further excavations in
those sites to
to be able to explain something or what
we are seeing right now
the big thing is that we can say there
is
new civilization new culture waiting for
us to be
to study them with so much to excavate
most of the work on these newly
discovered structures will be done by
the next generation of archaeologists
but haiko is not unhappy with his own
contribution well for me his worked over
this last 20 25 years in that region
it's uh sort of a dream coming true to
say at the end of my career that well we
have a new culture
and
that's nice yeah i admit that